herzlich willkommen in meiner tor 12
heute möchte ich euch zeigen wie ich die
figur für den elefanten gemacht habe ich
habe die torte ja schon vor einiger zeit
veröffentlicht und habe aber die figur
noch nicht veröffentlicht und dieses
video heute wird ein kleines grundlagen
video und zwar zeige ich euch wie ihr
aus modelliermasse figuren herstellen
könnt ich habe jetzt als beispielen
elefanten aber ihr könnt mit meinem
prinzip dass ich da habe jede figur
herstellen die ihr wollt und ich werde
jetzt mit modelliermasse arbeiten das
ist sowas wie von dort aber da ist eben
noch 10 c pulver mit dabei
damit der von dorsch peter schön
aushärtet und die figur auch stabil
bleibt falls ihr solche figuren für eure
torten vorbereiten wollt könnt ihr
bereits eine woche oder zwei oder drei
wochen vor eurer torte herstellen und
einfach aushärten lassen und dann habt
ihr das schon mal fertig und misst dann
noch die figur machen und ich würde
sagen wir starten jetzt direkt mit dem
tutorial
hier habe ich jetzt etwas blüten passte
und hier etwas von doch ich werde jetzt
allerdings nur mit dem von dort arbeiten
und später cmc prüfe ein kneten damit
ich modelliermasse in erhalte ich nehme
jetzt schwarze lebensmittelfarbe und
färbe den weißen von torgau ein
ich habe jetzt hier auch schon ein stück
fertigen schwarzen von dort inhaltlich
vor einmal eingefärbt und diesen knete
ich jetzt ein um ein schönes helles grau
zu erhalten
ich finde hier übrigens die farben von
eco park weil man sie sehr leicht
passieren kann und weil sie auch
komplett zu frei sind
wichtig ist jetzt zu wissen wie groß
ihre figur sein soll
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier mal eine
platte mit 20 zentimetern durchmesser
genommen und meine modelliermasse wiegt
110 gramm hier knete ich jetzt etwa ein
viertel teelöffel cnc verein und dann
müsst ihr die modellierer setzer teilen
damit die proportionen stimmen
zuerst theilig sind euch drei ein teil
davon ist der körper ein teil ist der
kopf und den rest muss man nochmal
zerteilen die hälfte davon verwende ich
dann für die beine und die andere hälfte
verteile ich und nehmen einen teil für
die arme und den restlichen teil für den
rest also zum beispiel für dior für den
körper nehme ich jetzt das große stück
und form sie zu einer kugel und dann
etwas tropfenförmig das mache ich
einfach mit meinen fingern direkt auf
meinem kate und nehme mir dann die zwei
großen teile für die beine und formen
daraus auch erst mal eine kugel und dann
wieder länglich zu einem tropfen
hinten müssen die beine etwas abgeflacht
und etwas gerundet werden damit sie um
den körper herum passen und unten formen
wir jetzt noch den fuß indem wir einfach
ein kleines stück nach oben biegen und
dieses platt drücken wenn ich dann beide
beine ab klebig sie mit etwas cnc kleber
an und formen noch keine details hinein
für den kopf nehme ich jetzt von einem
reststück noch ein bisschen
modelliermasse dazu damit etwas größer
wird weil er auch der rüssel gleich mit
geformt wird
ich möchte da nämlich keinen übergang
haben und formen aus einer kugel so den
rüssel heraus dass vorne ein kleiner
kurzer rüssel entsteht
dann stelle ich den kopf auf dem tisch
und forme den rüssel zu recht machen
eine kleine wölbung für die augen rein
und nehme mir dann eine spritztour und
formt daraus den mund
den könnt ihr jetzt entweder zu lassen
oder noch etwas öffnen das mache ich
jetzt hier mit meinem modell ihr
werkzeug und öffnet den mund damit der
elefant und schönes großes lächeln
bekommt
wenn ihr dann zufrieden seid steckt ihr
eine spaghetti in den körper hinein
ihr könnt da auch cake pops stile nehmen
aber ich nehme gerne spaghetti weil sie
auch essbar sind und da kommt jetzt
etwas cnc kleber drauf und der kopf kann
dann drauf gesetzt werden
die arme freue mich genauso aus den zwei
kleinen kugeln die ich dann zu
tropfenform und legt sie erstmal
beiseite
jetzt möchte ich noch ein kleines tuch
formen und nehme dazu hellblaue
modelliermasse und rolle sie aus und
geht da einfach mal mit nem struktur
voller drüber und so den schönen effekt
drauf zu bekommen
dieses schneide ich dann mit meinem
werkzeug zurecht und möchte jetzt noch
dieses tool entfalten legen und das geht
am besten wenn ihr euch kleine
gegenstände darunter legt wie zum
beispiel pinsel oder kleine stifte
anschließend könnt ihr das tuch dann
einfach über die beine trümmer legen und
die arme dann ebenfalls mit cmc kleber
ankleben den zweiten arm habe ich dann
noch gestützt mit etwas küchenpapier
einfach damit das so in form bleibt und
in der position bleibt mit meinem auto
werde ich dann noch die vertiefungen in
den augen machen um da gleich die weißen
und schwarzen punkte hinein zu setzen
und das ist eine etwas kniffliger arbeit
aber ich finde es so sehen die augen bei
dem elefanten einfachen schönsten aus
dann nehme ich mir denn lebensmittel
stift das ist auch einer von eco park
und auch dieser ist komplett zu frei und
er hat jetzt eine dicke und eine dünne
seite und ich verwende gerne die dicke
seite weil sie vorne eine schöne spitze
hat um ganz kleine feinheiten zu malen
und damit male ich jetzt noch zwei drei
wimpern damit ich einfach ein paar
details mehr haben und mit dem
restlichen grau weiß ich jetzt noch die
ohren formen in dem ich das graue stück
länglich aus rolle und in zwei teilen so
schneide und dann etwas blaue
modelliermasse nehme und das innere vom
ohr formel dafür nehme ich wieder so
eine spritze und schlechter mit kreise
aus legt diese über die ohren drüber und
passe sie an
und auf meinem schaumstoff pad dünne ich
die ohren jetzt am rand etwas aus so
macht man das beispielsweise bei blumen
und ich hab jetzt diese methode
verwendet um die ohren etwas dünner zu
gestalten
diese klebe ich dann auch mit etwas cnc
kleber an
und auch hier müsst ihr falls sie nicht
sofort halten mit etwas küchenpapier
nachhelfen und es einfach so trocknen
lassen
jetzt stelle ich mir noch vier kleine
kreise aus
hinten mache ich dann noch eine kleine
vertiefung hinein für den schwanz den
habe ich aus den minimalen resten
geformt die ich noch übrig hatte
und mit etwas cnc kleber rein fiktiv
jetzt möchte ich den ballon formen und
ich habe es hier das hellblau mit dem
grün vermischt mit der passenden farbe
grün und habe es so ein schönes türkis
erhalten
für den luftballon müsst ihr eine kugel
formen und auch hier kommt ebenfalls cnc
pulver hinein und die kugelform tier
dann zu einem tropfen und aus einem
kleinen rest habe ich jetzt zum beispiel
in der kleine blume ausgestochen und
diese dann unten am ballon befestigt der
ballon muss dann erst komplett trocknen
bis er weiter verwendet wird mit etwas
pulver farbe im rot habe ich jetzt noch
die backen des elefanten etwas wirklich
eingefärbt und da müsst ihr die farbe
auf dem pinsel auftragen und etwas ab
rudern auf zum beispiel den cache bord
damit ihr nicht so viel farbe auf einmal
habt damit das ganze schön verblendet
werden kann
mit der blauen kristall farbe habe ich
dann noch das tuch etwas eingebürgert
und ich habe hier wie ihr sehen könnt
den luftballon ausgetauscht gegen einen
roten weil es meiner meinung nach besser
gepasst hat hier erhitze ich jetzt
gerade einen draht und steckte ihn in
den luftballon hinein und so könnt ihr
das ganze dann erst einmal trocknen
lassen
die figur durfte dann vier tage trocknen
bis ich sie auf der torte gesetzt habe
und dort könnt ihr sie noch mal etwas
auffrischen in dem ihr back grinst ray
darüber gibt dann glänzt die figur schön
und zum schluss müsst ihr dann nur noch
den draht des luftballons erhitzen und
in den rüssel hineinstecken
ich hoffe ich konnte euch mit diesem
tutorial etwas helfen und ihr könnt nun
auch eure eigenen figuren herstellen
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall ganz
viel spaß dabei freue mich darauf wenn
ihr mir fotos auf facebook oder
instagram sendet und übrigens habe ich
jetzt auch im neuen blog den findet ihr
auf www sallys blog.de dass alle rezepte
in kategorien eingeteilt und von a bis z
sortiert ich freue mich aufs nächste mal